Bye kids I'll keep an eye out for my grandkid
in space you're what oh right Naruto thanks
for visiting Space Beth.
Welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this will be my full Rick and Morty Season
six episode three video there were a whole bunch
of Easter eggs and references so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel I'll
be doing videos for all the episodes of the Season
be sure to subscribe to get them careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen it
yet we'll just start at the beginning and work our
way through scene by a scene talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments as we go along starting with
the episode title bethic twin stinked which is
a reference to the movie Basic Instinct one of
the spiciest crime Thrillers of the 90s it was
a pretty spicy episode but the actual plot of the
episode has nothing to do with the actual plot of
the movie like they were just using the name as
the parody it's mostly a Beth episode about both
of the best space Beth and the version at home
I'll just call her home Beth for the purposes
of this video and the idea is that they're meant
to be so like Rick they're just as narcissistic
as Rick is of course they would be into themselves
the same way that Rick is kind of into himself in
fact later in the episode Rick reveals because
he's seen the infinite Ricks like he's been
to so many different realities he's seen every
possible permutation of the family so he's been in
similar situations has happened in this episode
but also he himself has forgotten the ice cream
which is a reference to him getting it on with
other versions of Rick's from other realities
before like it's Rick so he's literally done and
seen every possible thing so he has contingency
plans for everything which is why he has the
backup ice cream in his little freezer there
which is also why he aggressively does not care
what they actually do during the episode like I
don't care what you do but it's gonna get really
difficult if you keep lying to the family about
this so basically they use the episode to do a
deep dive in best personality and is mostly about
home Beth because space Beth did leave did Explore
her potential but home Beth did not so that's kind
of what she does during this episode like kind of
explore what she's capable of which they make a
reference to at the end of the episode as well
when Jerry flashes back and his friend is like
dude don't do it she's too hardcore for you she's
gonna break you which she kind of does briefly at
the end of the episode when he puts himself into
that special shell the way the writers talked
about the best in the episode is they were meant
to feel kind of like young versions of Rick so
Rick kind of went through a similar Arc exploring
his potential when he first set off to find prime
rig way earlier in his timeline we've seen some
of his Early Adventures like we've seen him get
crazy with some of the other rigs before but
he always implies stuff like this like there
are thousands and thousands of Adventures that
they'll probably never have time to actually
show us on screen there's so many of them maybe
if Rick and Morty really does go like 100 Seasons
so the best get kind of like a speed run version
of Rick's complete Arc to where he is in present
day I don't know how many episodes they plan on
having space Beth in this season but the way she
leaves at the end of the episode makes it sound
like she won't be back for a while and if they
do reference their little three-way thing that
they have going on between them again in future
episodes it'll probably be more as a joke the same
way that they make a joke referencing Naruto Morty
and Summers giant space baby like remember the
time that the two of you had a baby together
that's still a thing out there floating around
maybe it'll come back someday during the cold
open we find out it's the Thanksgiving episode
space Beth brought Morty like the brand new XL
poop lickian game console they use it for a bunch
of video game parodies turkey Rick is meant to be
a reference the U.S president pardoning him and
Morty again for crimes they may have committed the
previous year during the season 5 Thanksgiving
episode they revealed that Rick has been using
this trick for years to Pardon all of his crimes
that he commits every single year they reference
Rick's lack of portals again I don't know how
long that's going to last but eventually he'll
probably fix it rick reveals currently he started
changing his clothes using something similar to
the nanites like Black Panther and Iron Man
use because he doesn't have portals anymore
previously in episode 1 they made a joke about
him using portals to travel to other realities
and steal clean pairs of clothes from alternate
reality versions of Rick rather than do laundry
with his own clothes Jerry's whole toast about
how badly he needs Beth just to continue living
it's just more to highlight how much home Beth
has been ignoring her own potential just because
the family's been holding her down this whole time
kind of like she's had no time to explore herself
and that's basically what this episode is is space
Beth coming to remind her that and they explore
literally and metaphorically themselves like they
go full Loki even though they're clones you could
make the Loki reference like Loki getting it on
with a version of himself from another timeline
Loki would be proud of this episode space Beth
reveals her spaceship is like a tardis bigger on
the inside so it's a flying house basically she's
got a ton of Predator weapons in there apparently
too when she says Rick calls it a hack that's a
reference to Dan Harmon and Justin Roiland saying
that Rick is meant to feel kind of like a parody
of Doctor Who mixed with Doc Brown from Back to
the Future the venusian wine getting them buzzed
is what pushes them over the edge to go full Loki
with themselves which is why Rick hides it at the
end of the episode like he believes that this is
the true reason why this happened and if you don't
speak French the venusian language that they start
speaking is basically real life French the whole
joke here is that Sarah chalky who voices Beth can
actually speak fluent French so they just let her
have fun with that in this episode the song that
she sings in French is the major general song from
the Gilbert and Sullivan comic Opera Pirates of
Penzance so Beth is apparently also a big theater
nerd on top of everything else then all the Video
Game parodies are mostly meant to be jokes about
the poor mechanics of games just in general and
also jokes about how lame the games would be if
they were hyper realistic like The Asteroids game
is based on the real-life Asteroids game but
the joke being that what if it were real you
wouldn't see any asteroids you'd be traveling
through the vacuum of space for forever just to
try to find something and that's why the game has
Morty recorded the message because he would really
starve if it were real life the controllers that
Rick later tries to reverse engineer seem like
they're based on like a combination of PlayStation
controllers and Super Nintendo controllers when
summer finally catches both the best she freaks
out the energy drink that she starts guzzling is
called battery acid it looks kind of like Monster
Energy which is also a joke about how most energy
drinks aren't much better for you than actually
drinking battery acid but please do not drink
battery acid their version of Street Fighter seems
like it's closer to Street Fighter 5. kick puncher
looks like a parody of Ryu tube steak looks like
Blanca but if you watch the community series the
kick puncher name is a big community easter egg
during that series kick puncher was the hero of
a movie franchise that Troian Abed kept talking
about tube steak pretty obvious reference that's
just a reference to your dong Jerry completes
the horse puzzle because Beth is also obsessed
with horses there's horse themed stuff all over
the house which Rick later references like he
calls both the best Sapphic horse girls when they
say they're going to the Gloppy drop system for
ice cream that was previously referenced in the
wedding squashers episode and as Rick explains
their race is ice cream is like the best ice cream
in the Multiverse space Beth reveals she has her
own small space station she uses an apartment
orbiting Earth we also find out she keeps a
family photo there meaning that she actually
does miss the family even though she seems like
she doesn't during the episode then when Morty
catches them it almost looks like he breaks the
fourth wall here and that would be a first for
him I don't think we've ever actually seen him
break the fourth wall in an episode before but
the way they cut the transition I think they
play it so that you could think it is a fourth
wall break or it's not a fourth wall break then
probably the most interesting thing here during
this conversation that Beth has with Rick when
she reveals what really happened is him revealing
that he's literally seen and done everything so he
himself has seen what she's done before so he's
not surprised by that but he himself has also
done it with other versions of himself and other
realities so thus he has the contingency plan of
the ice cream just in case the same thing happens
in this reality which it just did when he's giving
her advice it also sounds like he doesn't like
credit cards credit in general or just taking out
loans all about staying liquid don't want to pay
that interest when they're on the rooftop smoking
you notice the smoke that they blow is based on
what they're currently thinking about so space
Beth blows a middle finger flipping someone off
in home Beth blows Jerry's face the next video
from the game but because they're doing the
whole hyper realistic thing the whole idea is
that the sword is too big and heavy for him to
actually pick it up I'm not sure who the giant
crustacean is meant to be a reference to I think
the whole thing with the infinite console screen
is meant to show you that the game has access to
an infinite library of games but they're all kind
of like Lane games like this the next parody being
an overt reference to the affair that the Bez are
having but done in the style of like a jrpg tech
space relationship game like a dating Sim the
worst dating Sim you've ever seen then we find
out that Rick has a working Hollow deck inside
the house and when he says they went full San
Junipero that's a reference to the Black Mirror
episode of the same name where two women fall in
love and live out the rest of their lives inside
a matrix like simulation like this then when they
reveal the truth at dinner Jerry has the flashback
that's just meant to show you how Beth has all
this potential that she's never really actually
explored and that's why this is playing out
during this episode because it's finally coming
out of her like oh wow I never thought about doing
something like this is this what I'm capable of we
find out that Rick has upgraded Jerry's body with
a shell defense mechanism that he uses anytime
there's something that he just can't or doesn't
want to deal with and that will just continue
in future episodes like he'll have that ability
going forward now he also reveals that Jerry can
turn into a full-on Shrek if they try to force
the shell open also clowning on Wonder Woman
1984 just being a lame movie then the text-based
game might seem familiar if you play games back
in the 1970s like this is probably 2 too old for
most people watching this video but some of you
may have actually played the game back in the day
it's a Mainframe game called Wander from 1974 like
a text-based game there are lots of clones of this
but this is based on one of the original ones from
back in 1974 that basically plays out exactly the
way that you see in the episode it's just like a
text-based game where it gives you little queries
you type responses and it'll just generate Things
based on that the joke about the Vampire ending in
the clearing is just a joke about people having to
play the real version of the game back in the
day with similar circumstances like weird crazy
stuff would happen and because it's just text you
wouldn't have warning of what might happen next
it almost seems like Morty breaks the fourth ball
again like almost breaks the fourth wall but not
quite when he references the fact that they're in
a television show Trope of kids and sitcoms that
never age like The Simpsons so like how many times
have we done this Thanksgiving before how old are
we this is the memory device from Morty's mind
blowers that they want Rick to use he makes an
Eternal Sunshine reference because in that movie
Jim Carrey's character wanted all history of his
relationship and his love of Kate Winslow's
character taken from his mind the multiplicity
reference is to the Michael Keaton movie where
he clones himself implying with the joke is that
the Clones got it on with themselves during that
movie and like I mentioned earlier when he says
the two of them are gonna attack him later when
the memory wipe fails he's actually talking from
experience because as he said he's seen it all
so he's been in scenarios where that's happened
where it hasn't worked and they've attacked
him which is why he goes through this whole
thing so unsurprised by every turn like yeah yeah
whatever let's get on with this Jerry apparently
reveals he has a weird little junk like he just
seems fixated on it and it just comes out during
their argument here like wow you seem like you've
been thinking about this for a long time and when
some are reference getting themselves another
Jerry they actually literally just did that in
episode one or actually kind of the reverse of
that like they found that they'd had a different
Jerry this whole time and went back to get the
original one the way the writers talked about
the weird three-way thing they have going on
at the end of the episode is that they could
always reference it in future episodes like it
could potentially become a thing but at most I
think they'll just use it for comedy like they'll
reference it in funny ways in future episodes the
same way that they make the joke about the giant
Naruto baby at the end of this episode like oh
yeah that thing is still out there remember we
did that once upon a time a little while ago and
the way they play Space Beth leaving this sounds
like it's going to be the last episode we'll see
her in for a while she might come back before the
end of this season but like I think it's going to
be a little while the lesson Rick is referencing
when he says he also learns something this week
is that he shouldn't leave the venusian wine
out because he blames that on everything that
happened during the episode and stows it in
that hidden cabinet also zoom and enhance in
the background here there's this freaky little
tiny Morty stuck inside the bottle of liquor
like a Morty tequila worm or something his eyes
are closed so I'm assuming he's dead beneath it
there's a me six box and next to it is a container
that looks like a hairy ball sack so you can let
me know in the comments what do you think that
container is for like what does he use that for
in the post-credits scene they reveal that Jerry
or other Jerry's multiple Jerry's visit the Jerry
Berry daycare which we just saw in episode one
to get it on with with themselves sometimes in
really weird ways so like as weird as Beth got
in this episode Jerry is just as weird but if
you spotted any other Easter eggs and references
in the episode that I didn't mention in the video
just write them Below in the comments in my full
episode 4 video will post next week after they
release it big reminder that the Star Wars and
or episodes are starting this week episodes one
through three are dropping tomorrow my video
for that will post on Wednesday so make sure
to enable alerts from my channel so you don't
miss that everyone click here for my house of
the Dragon episode 6 trailer video and click
here for all my Rick and Morty episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!